Let's see if we can write
0.0727 as a fraction.
Now, let's just think about
what places these are in.
This is in the tenths place.
This is in the hundredths place.
This 2 is in the
thousandths place.
And this 7 right
here, this last 7,
is in the ten-thousandths place.
So there's a couple of
ways we can do this.
The way I like to think of
this, this term over here
is in the ten-thousandths place.
We can view this whole
thing right over here
as 727 ten-thousandths because
this is the smallest place
right over here.
So let's just rewrite it.
This is equal to
727 over 10,000.
And we've already
written it as a fraction.
And I think that's about as
simplified as we can get.
This number up here
is not divisible by 2.
It's not divisible by 5.
In fact, it's not
divisible by 3,
which means it wouldn't
be divisible by 6 or 9.
It doesn't even seem
to be divisible by 7.
It might be a prime number.
But I think we are done.